-(APPLAUSE)
-Yes. (CHUCKLES)
Uh, Andrew Ross Sorkin,
do you agree with Larry Kudlow
that Medicare
and Social Security should be
handed to Wall Street
through privatization,
is that what he's for?
-I'm sure he is.
-I'm sure he is for it.
-BILL: Yeah.
-I don't think I'm for that.
No, I'm gonna take
the other side of that.
Is that where you want me to go?
Well, I don't know.
What are you trying to
check in with me for?
I'm asking you the question.
-No, I think that's--
-BILL: I mean,
Bush proposed this.
I think that's a real problem.
I think the privatization of
so many things actually--
Especially when it comes to
people's pensions
and retirement,
part of our problem
has been that.
So, I'm gonna
take the other side.
-But as an economist,
only I'm not...
-ANDREW: Who plays one on TV.
...I'm just gonna give you
the other argument.
ANDREW: Okay, go for it.
I've seen the chart of where
money... (CHUCKLES)
If you put your money
in the stock market,
versus if you just put it
in the bank or whatever it is...
ANDREW: Yes, it'll do better
in the market.
...the market one
goes like this.
Now, you can't watch it
every year because the market
goes up and down,
but over the time,
if you put it in
when you were 20,
by the time you retired at 65,
the money goes like this and--
-If we had a forced
savings program, by the way...
-BILL: I'm just saying.
If we had real
forced savings program,
where you couldn't take it out
and was effectively gonna be
managed elsewhere
and there was guarantees on it,
I could actually go for that.
Yeah, it's not
the craziest idea...
ANDREW: Not the craziest idea
in the world.
...that Bush-- Bush, hey.
Who is he to you?
Is he your uncle? George Bush.
-W?
-BILL: Yeah.
He's my, uh-- He's my cousin.
BILL:
You had to think about that.
Yeah, there's a lot of us there,
cousins.
-Yeah, his dad's my uncle,
I'm pretty sure of it.
-BILL: Okay.
(LAUGHING)
PETE: You guys hang out?
Uh, there's a lot of us, no,
not much.
So, Billy, "How is the rest of
the Bush family holding up
under Trump," this card says.
Trying to take the high road,
I think.
-I don't know if he's--
-Right.
I'm not sure either one
cast a vote for him.
In fact,
I'm pretty sure they didn't.
Speaking of Me Too stuff, boy,
the old man sure skated
on the ass grabbing.
(LAUGHING)
Have you ever talked
to him about that?
I told him, "Never again,
you hear me? Don't do that." No.
(LAUGHS)
But-- Because there's
a conservative, I mean,
sounds like the same thing
that Al Franken was accused of
and that just kind of, like,
went into the ether. Okay.
Except he's a former president
of the United States who,
you know,
people didn't know that about.
And there's a whole bunch
of women that've said that,
it's pretty messed up.
Pretty unacceptable.
And there was a joke
that went with it,
it's disgusting and inexcusable.
BILL: Right you are.
These people--
What a lot of fun you are.
Well, I mean, he has a...
I mean... Okay.
ANDREW: There's no upside, yeah,
I'm with you.
I'm not sure
what Al Franken did.
I'll just say that.
I'm talking about Pappy,
either one, I mean,
who's grabbing people like that
in a photo op? It's weird.
It is weird, esp-- And--
Everybody wants a photo with
Bill Maher,
have you ever even considered--
I don't even touch people.
-BILL:
I take pictures like this.
-Yes, exactly.
(LAUGHING)
Every picture
I take is like this.
-Exactly, yeah.
-Hands up.
(LAUGHING)
Okay. "Why does the NRA
get a tax exemption
and how do we take it away?"
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
PETE: Elect Democrats.
That's a good--
Because they do run--
They would like to say that
they don't run
a political action committee,
but they do have that wing,
otherwise they say they're
a grassroots non-profit
organization, but they use legal
corporate tax loopholes
to build out an entire
political lobbying wing
that doesn't get taxed.
So that's
a corporate tax loophole,
but that's also because
the NRA knows how
to work the system.
BILL: Boy, do they.
And they know
how to use a crisis.
They never let
a crisis go to waste.
If you follow the money
on the NRA--
BILL: Now we're arming teachers.
PETE: Not yet.
BILL:
They somehow turn that around--
NAYYERA: You know, one shot
a student the other day.
Sure, it's moving ahead
in many states.
Somehow they turn that around
to a way they can
sell more guns.
It's moving ahead in the States
where they still
beat kids with paddles.
I mean, it's not--
You know, I don't think
it's taking hold.
Certainly it's not--
There's no agreement amongst
educators and experts
about arming teachers,
teachers don't want that.
ANDREW: One thing that
I was just gonna say on money
on the NRA,
you know, you can go after them
on the taxes or whatever it is,
but the real thing,
the real opportunity,
given I cover
the world of finance,
is the companies.
It's all the companies that
do business with the NRA
and people who
do business with guns,
it's the credit card companies
that allow the transactions
on the cards,
it's Apple TV, and Amazon,
and everybody who allows
this stuff over their airwaves,
that's--
(APPLAUSE)
Washington, unfortunately,
is not gonna do anything,
I don't think,
anytime soon, I could be wrong,
I hope I'm wrong,
but I think in the meantime,
there's a huge swath of stuff
that can actually happen,
but it depends on everyone
actually doing something
about it.
And that goes for the action
related to your pocket book,
right?
Consumers have to wait
about two years before we can
use our power as citizens
to kick somebody out of office,
I can make the decision tomorrow
if I want to go
to a different store.
If I don't like-- Like Walmart,
Walmart, um--
They getting your business?
Uh, they got the business of
a lot of people out of that day.
Right? (LAUGHS)
But Dick's Sporting Goods did.
-BILL: Yeah.
-NAYYERA: Mm-hmm.
-BILL: I got-- I, uh...
-(SCATTERED APPLAUSE)
I got paddled a couple of times.
-NAYYERA: Hey now.
-Didn't seem to destroy me.
You know, but...
Only when you do something
really bad, you know...
-You know--
-NAYYERA:
I wasn't sure what kind of
paddle you were talking about,
Bill.
Didn't have nails in it
or anything. It was--
I'm not quite sure what paddling
he's talking about,
but maybe we should move on.
(LAUGHING)
I'm just saying.
Uh, "If you worked
in the White House,
would you resign on principle
or stay to help minimize
the damage Trump causes?"
Oh, so, I, um-- I don't think
there's any heroism in
serving in this White House
anymore.
I think initially people really
did think that--
Like John Kelly, he was like,
"I'm gonna serve my country
and do this."
But it's, um--
You're not serving the public
at this point, right?
You're serving Trump
and his personal Trump interests
and that's just not--
PETE: And you don't know what
they are.
Right, but it's actually
very clear what they are,
they're advancing his family
and whoever else is willing to
line his pocket books,
whether it be Russian oligarchs
or any other dictators
that he may
or may not want to emulate.
But there is-- And yes,
I did work in the White House
and there is absolutely
no question that I would ever
work in a Trump White House
and the sad thing is
everybody who's walked out
has walked out tarnished.
Like, it's a dead end job now.
Icarus, fly close to the sun.
-NAYYERA: Right.
-Yes.
Monica Lewinsky has a better
reputation than
Sean Spicer does.
BILL: Who does?
Monica Lewinsky is doing better
brand-wise than Sean Spicer,
the former
White House press secretary.
No, anybody, as you can attest,
anybody who gets in contact,
he's a human wood chipper,
people just--
Everything he touches dies!
If you don't have the courage
to say no to a job
to Donald Trump,
you shouldn't be running
a McDonald's,
much less a White House.
But we have a problem.
I do wanna throw in
about public, like,
public servants who are--
I was a political appointee,
there are public servants
and the foreign service,
the military, civil servants,
who keep the day to day function
of government running,
the fact that they are feeling
demoralized is a massive problem
because they're the ones who
make sure we, you know,
get things like our
social security checks.
All I was gonna say is,
the real problem though is if--
Look, you can call all
the people who showed up
in the beginning opportunists,
which they are.
Today,
the new people are believers,
and fortunately
or unfortunately,
but fortunately for Trump
and unfortunately maybe
for everybody else.
PETE:
Sycophants and cartoon villains.
But the opportunists,
to the degree you thought that
they were saving the country
from Trump,
those people
don't exist anymore.
And so I think there has to be
some thought about
whether you do want some
diversity of thought
in the room.
Even if it's gonna taint people,
I don't know what
the right answer is.
He has to want the diversity
of thought in the room.
But he doesn't.
Exactly, so, like, what do you
get out of serving?
-How are you gonna fix anything?
-PETE: He doesn't want
any thought in the room.
But that's what they're claiming
these days, all over TV,
is that he w--
That's why there's
this turnover, he has this--
He says he likes to see people
go at it in a fight.
And I'm like, "This is the guy
who's going to negotiate with
Kim Jong Un?"
Like... (GRUNTS)
"I like to see people go at it."
BILLY: This is how we know him,
the boardroom.
He's the host of The Apprentice,
"You're fired", he instigates.
They're all about selling
lemonade on a corner
in 5th Avenue--
It wasn't like it was all there
for us to judge.
But he made voters think he'd
be able to take business savvy
and apply that to politics
and all these other things
and policy--
So many people are complicit
in that though, don't you think?
It is, and it's shady business
deals,
that's the problem,
it works in real estate,
but it doesn't work in diplomacy
or policy.
How many of those voters that
he convinces--
This is my question.
How many of those voters
that he did convince,
uh, you know, have changed
their mind?
Or more importantly,
has anybody said,
since Trump was elected,
"You know, I was really against
him the whole time,
but in these 14 months
he's really impressed me."
(LAUGHING)
"I think I'm gonna reconsider
my vote for November."
That's, like, one guy who's
a pig farmer.
I think there are.
Really?
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, panel.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)